nur diejenigen personen die es richtig
erraten hat oder als erster richtig
erraten hat der werde ich ein gedicht
schreiben
servus sgz willkommen zu einer neuen
folge von ein behindertes projekt was
ich mir gerade eben ausgedacht habe und
zwar aber ich wollte etwas ausgabe jetzt
habe das könnte wirklich wirklich lustig
werden und zwar werde ich heute einfach
mal hier so ein ründchen spiel hört sich
ganz normal aber im laufe dieser runde
irgendwann irgendwann im laufe dieser
folge ich sage euch nicht wann werte
werde ich über die folge verteilt meine
drei aktuellen lieblingslieder summen ja
und ihr könnt ihr erraten
beziehungsweise wenn ihr die erwartet
und richtig rad wenn ihr alle drei bäder
richtig ratet und mir die korrekt in die
kommentare schreibt also ihr müsst es in
die kommentare schreiben was ihr denkt
dass es ist dann verspreche ich euch
dann schreibe ich euch also derjenigen
person nutzer nur diejenigen personen
die es richtig erraten hat oder als
erster richtig erraten hat das kann man
herausfinden
in den kommentaren und was will jeder
der werde ich ein gedicht schreiben den
inhalt kann diese person selbst
bestimmen ihr könnt dann einfach mit den
liedern die er in die kommentare
schreibt könnte dann schreiben ja ich
hätte gern ein gedicht in dem du
beschreibst die wunderbar ich in
minecraft pvp bin oder irgendwas könnt
ihr euch wünschen dass eure freie
entscheidung und ich werde dann die 4
dieses gericht schreiben und natürlich
werde ich werde ein bisschen lustig
mache aber es wird so werden wir es euch
wünscht und ja ich würde einfach sagen
lange rede kurzer sinn drei lieder
werden dieser folge gesunken die kann
man alle kennen also keins ist wirklich
unbekannt
wir sind alle richtig bekannt als
rüstung und ja hört gut zu passt auf
bleibt dran
schaut die folge bis zum ende durch
damit ihr alle lieder erkennen könnt und
mit ein bisschen glück wenn jetzt
richtig ratet seid ihr dann im nächsten
video denn dieses gedicht was ich euch
schreiben werde ich euch natürlich auf
einem video vorlesen vielleicht im
nächsten schon aber es kann auch sein
dass es gar niemand geredet jetzt
theoretisch falls ihr seid und keine
kommentare schreibt kann es natürlich
sein dass keiner das erregt weil sich
ihr denkt auch ich schaffe es bestimmt
nicht und ich habe keinen kommentar
also schreibt zu viele kommentare wie es
geht
ratet ratet fleißig weil ich habe
richtig lust darauf ich jetzt einfach
mal mannheims letzten gedicht
geschrieben
keine ahnung in fucking grundschule ist
sicher also seid so nett und ratet rat
fleißig und damit ihr rat fleißig gipser
und xxx das war bestimmt mädel mit dem
namen und ratet freising ich habe
richtig lust drauf so dann fangen wir
einfach die phase an wo ich einfach ganz
normal spiele bisschen was erzähle
unternehmen wir das machen werde so so
so so so den nie court in eisenstadt ich
glaube ja nie in der politik berlin
wahrscheinlich dieser nicola dieser nico
dauernd seien ja wohl schon sagen okay
alter derart eigentlich gut gemacht aber
finden sie dass ihr das leben gerettet
das war doch relativ lucky leute ich
hoffe dass ich gut genug summe für euch
ansonsten wartet einfach
ratet einfach was es sein könnte dass
hier vielleicht geben wir einfachen
tipps zu jedem lied das ist ein lied von
einem deutschen künstler mit einem wie
soll man sagen hier ähnlichen namen kann
man das sagen
ich glaube ich gibt so viele tipps also
wartet weiß ich glaube das konnte man
erkennen die balance des instituts ins
theater ins texten reindrücken gewichen
protein und die games weg vom bag
direktor einer pizza
so der brand immer noch und das top
match haben wir gewonnen
die alles klar und hier geht einfach mal
spontan in die nächste runde wird nicht
selbst was wenn man ein spiel gespielt
haben wir jetzt aber ist so bekannt in
der youtube szene alter ist müsst ihr
kennen
das ist noch nach zeigt dass du das
gehört noch zu dem zweiten lied gib mir
dass man jedes mal jetzt nämlich gerne
wir gehen dann fick profitiert den usa
wenn es doch mal hier
der kunststiftung danke danke super flu
also ich bin zu tun so krass jetzt schon
zwei liter gesund ich hoffe ihr konnte
das zweite erkennen dass es schwierig zu
summen
aber es ist echt so bekannt also und ist
auch mega aktuell also ihr müsst das
kenne ich glaube die werden
wahrscheinlich schon bereits erkannt
haben und denken aber nicht so viel über
dieses video nicht so klar
dann habe ich die man so viel über
dieses video läuft eigentlich bisher
also ich muss auch sagen letzter zeit
habe ich gerade im zweifel erst meine
kappe gepustet richtig gas verbessert
hat er uns gesehen wahrscheinlich schon
aus den augen könne dass bspw
juli vorgesehen
zack der ist weg okay okay das ist auch
weg hatte er noch was gefunden er hat er
nicht dahin kommen warum laufen das auch
mal recht viele kisten der sind auch im
recht viele kisten gegner an der ecke
konnte sie so wiederum haben kann er
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr tun als
die super gemacht
du bist du jetzt also wieder hoch
geflogen
meine fresse ach du scheiße das gibt es
nicht unter fakt das war richtig ab
gesprächs oder
sie haben jetzt eigentlich alles
komplett so bogen
da passt so weit wie die sagen guter
sprung gemacht aber leider kein kompass
nennen da dies bisschen scheiße ein
kleines bisschen zeit ist das bloß
letzte gegner wo ich sehr zügig nach
oben das bedeuten dass bedeuten
das war nichts platz zurück gepackt
am komenden bahrain hinter der war
vorgestern versteht darum denke director
cliff burton ein junger vater bahn was
sie aber nicht
da passiert nichts unter feuer brennt
das passiert auch nichts weil das
fahrzeug sind aber dafür kann ich auch
nicht geben
amigo wo ist der andere
die 3 liga habe ich jetzt gesund jetzt
gerade eben noch mit beginn des des
death metal das letzte lied ich hoffe
alle erkennen
ich hoffe ich habe nicht zu undeutlich
gesund falls ich doch zu undeutlich
gesundheit wiederholen wir das einfach
nochmal weil ich die diese these lustig
findet nichts machen so lustig bei marie
wichtig
so hält der vater hat immer mit direkt
durch den durch gelungen all das hat der
sv mein gott oh mein gott das war die
dümmste ruf aller zeiten hat das gesehen
er läuft zu verstehen also haut ist
etwas auf den boden und zündet sich
selbst anderen stirbt daran
trotzdem ge kollege hasse egal nicht so
schlecht gemacht
also leute ich hab so lag schreibt fest
in die kommentare welche lieder erraten
habt und wie gesagt ein bisschen glück
bleibt schreibt ein gericht vielleicht
deckels liebesgedicht oder ein kleines
gedicht unter browse wie ihr wollt eure
tipps euren 1 besagt man nicht
ratschläge nein
eure vermutung schreibt eure vermutung
in die kommentare 123 in der reihenfolge
und dann sehen was beim nächsten video
wieder vielleicht mit einem gedicht für
dich bis dahin rein macht gut und geben